when joe biden and democrats were able
to pass their 1.9 trillion dollar
coveted relief bill there was some news
that
tax reform might be joe biden's next
a big legislative goal and we talked
last week about what is expected to be
in that tax reform plan we talked with
bill share
about the political feasibility
remembering that there are many
democrats who
don't necessarily support all aspects of
what joe biden wants to do
from the standpoint of tax reform but
now it looks like it may not actually be
tax reform that joe biden and his
administration tackle next there's a
report from the associated press
that it may be a very large a three
trillion dollar
i guess we're calling it an
infrastructure package but it's really
like
an infrastructure schools and
families package and uh joe biden
reportedly monday met with
senate democrats to start laying the
groundwork for what would be
a spending package that would deal with
many aspects of american infrastructure
that are sadly outdated we've needed
like real i don't mean you drive by
and that stretch of road near your house
is under construction for two years and
it's never really clear what they're
doing but eventually it gets done and
i'm not talking about that i'm talking
about
major repair and replacement of
significant
american infrastructure we're talking
about uh
new development of roads we're talking
about
a refreshing hospital infrastructure
green
energy systems you know a lot of these
different things
and reportedly this is exactly what joe
biden is looking at
next three trillion dollars in total
and it will include money for schools it
will include money
uh for families and it would be divided
up
could be a third a third a third again
this is all early but it looks like it
could be about a trillion dollars
for roads bridges rail lines electrical
vehicle charging stations
and a cellular network and the idea
would be
start pushing towards clean energy but
do it in
in an economically competitive way which
is what
we've been saying for all all this time
the idea is not
uh necessarily uh to take things out of
the market but it's
let's have fair markets where we're not
subsidizing the wrong
things the second piece of it which is
the school piece
would include investments in workers by
providing free community college
universal pre-k pre-kindergarten and
paid family leave another aspect that
we've been talking about for a while
which many on the right see
as quote handouts remember it's our tax
money that's then being being used for
programs
to call them handouts is wrong
fundamentally but it also ignores that
when you're doing something that allows
people to be more economically
productive
it should fit under the umbrella of what
the so-called
free enterprise people would also want
now that three trillion dollar number
is obviously a number that is going to
lead to
the predictable and and uh regular
refrains
from the right and i think that
hopefully democrats will realize
we're not going to get votes from
republicans anyway so let's not care
about the fact that they're going to
talk about we don't have the money
where's the money going to come from et
cetera et cetera
they're going to do that regardless they
would do it if it was 2 trillion
they did it with 800 billion when it was
barack obama's spending program they're
going to do it regardless so hopefully
that's not something that is going to be
affecting the way that democrats go
about this and fundamentally as i said
when when donald trump lost and remember
we knew that on november 8th of 2020 we
didn't have to wait until january 20th
to know that
i said these two years will be a test
in two ways one can republicans
obstruct everything and still get
themselves re-elected
the answer may be yes and we'll actually
talk later today about how even though
every republican voted against coveted
stimulus a few weeks ago
one-third of republicans republican
voters
think that their republican elected
officials voted for coveted stimulus so
they may be able to obstruct
and not get punished by their voters
because their voters are so clueless
that's number one but number two
it's a test of what can you get done
when you have a two-year period
with the white house the house and the
senate we've seen these periods before
um and uh we we the infrastructure
spending needs to happen
it's been necessary for decades we are
able to count on
zero republican senators to vote for it
their efforts will be obstruction
because ultimately they are cult members
they turned over the party to donald
trump when it became clear that
trump had the momentum and even if
privately they they were opposed to what
trump was doing
they stood aside i guess because they
wanted to get their judges done or
whatever the case may be
and i know that one of the talking
points they may come up with and
and unfortunately this one resonates
even with some in my audience will be
three trillion dollars for all of this
different stuff why can't we just
separate it out
and do individual bills up and down
votes on each of these elements
and then it would be clearer what people
are in favor of or against because you
can always have republicans saying well
i'm not against doing some of this stuff
but we can't do all of it because of
item number one and item number seven
and twenty those are pork or those are
bad or whatever the case may be
what you have to remember is that bills
typically need
60 votes but you can get around that
through the budget reconciliation
process but you're limited
in how many times you can use that
process
once we know and we know that
republicans will not
actually negotiate in good faith they'll
find
if you change how you do the bill
they'll find you new ways to oppose it
what you have to understand
is that reconciliation and doing this
with
50 votes plus kamala is probably the
only way you get it done
if you separate this out into four or
eight or 12 different bills
republicans will then just find ways to
delay each individual bill
they might use different justifications
or the same one
the only way you really have a shot at
getting this done
is by doing it all together in what's
called an omnibus bill
and passing it through budget
reconciliation so ultimately
they would say republicans oh break it
up and then we'll do individual votes on
the merits of each one of these
then they would just obstruct and use
delay tactics to make sure that as few
of those things
actually get a vote in the first place
and then they would still vote against
it in the end
so i i do think it's probably more
politically feasible
right now for biden to do this than the
tax stuff
that's that's a political feasibility
calculation
i think either way he's going to be
doing it with literally zero
republican support if you think some
republicans might vote for such a
spending bill
uh infrastructure bill let me know and
specifically let me know who
because i just don't see it today's
episode is sponsored by
bluechew a unique online service
delivering the same active ingredients
as viagra and cialis in a
chewable form and at a fraction of the
cost and they're giving my audience an
entire month's
supply for free take a short quiz on the
bluetooth website
a licensed doctor approves your
prescription and the medication goes
right to your home in a discreet package
no driving to the doctor's office
having a possibly awkward conversation
waiting in line at the pharmacy bluechu
replaces the entire process with a few
clicks
and way less expensive and all of
bluetooth tablets are made
in the united states so if you think you
could benefit from an extra boost of
confidence
go to bluechew.com the link is under
this video and they'll give you an
entire month's supply for
free when you use promo code pacman just
pay five dollars for shipping